one more chance this is mobile mix
anyway what's up everyone Persia here
from GameSpot and we are joined by bond
Sean the street fighter 5 evolution 2019
champion himself were actually just
really excited to break down this epic
grand final set Wow we've come all the
way in the beginning he was thinking
he's made her really big words made a
really nice run through the losers so he
must be in top form but I'm very very
knowledge is in the Rashid matchup I'm
very comfortable at it so I wasn't like
to shift a bother wanna have crouching
girl right away what Big Bird was really
going for was a kind of baiting with low
short a lot this widow walk so in
response to that I wish I was trying to
respond with them with my heavy normal
is a fierce in the Roundhouse but Big
Bird was able to kind of kind of
counteract what I was preparing for him
to do so that was a little bit tough
towards the beginning this guy is
putting on a master class right now
so CLE what do you think is the hardest
part of this matchup not you ever see
where she players now most of them are
really high level so it can be tough at
times but in Japan there are there are
tons of high level or she player and I
have a lot of Rashid experience so I was
thinking definitely that's gonna be an
advantage for me when we played in
casuals his place I was completely
different what the pod is up there dude
wow so that did throw me off a little
bit in the beginning and I realized that
I needed to adjust to that I mean he
goes up to oh right here
you know you said you were pretty
confident this man you weren't really
shook but he played extremely well did
he still feel that confidence in this
moment right here regardless of a score
hmm like I was prepared for the reset
like even if that happened I didn't
think I was out of it at all
where do you feel like was the turning
point in this set for you because
obviously like I feel like from this
moment on it was completely different
match but what was the exact turning
plan for you so initially the kid's
gonna come around here like it like I
said earlier she plays differently from
casuals so I realized that and I'm
starting to make my adjustments here
he's throwing out big normals heavy
buttons and I'm trying to counter that
with my heavy back that's kind of a
turning point of the set G walk one
dogma come on oh here you can wake yokai
so don't look there are the big buttons
first and they kind of get like with
punished or you know get stuff just so
being a little bit more patient on
throwing up the heavier heavier normals
but bulge and fighting on the right back
here's the champion this is the park
whenever you're forced to make these
adjustments what's the first thing that
you start to change the market there is
no clock so if you don't analyze what
you're losing to you're always just
gonna run into the same thing over and
over again so I'm I'm really analyzing
what I'm losing to and then starting it
the video but it's kind of letting stir
that you know I'm gonna kill nursery
means you can run it today I was only
running on two hours of sleep so if the
Red Bull wasn't there I definitely
wouldn't have made it this far so the
mentality here in his opinion he think
Big Bird can't be in an advantage by
doing his normal friend butters and
stuff like that he's taking more risk
being more erratic and I realized that
so my mentality was that I'm at an
advantage because because he's thrown
off he's not on his normal game plan no
I sit there blue scooter we don't kind
of panic here and trying to throw in
every skill and so that cost me to lose
that round
we'll come on then in the end I believe
I do win this round to win the
tournament but in my mind I feel like
even if I have lost this round I think I
would have been ok I still like me to
win so it's a win the side I mean it's
clear adjustments are already being me
it's a whole nother set definitely would
have been in your favor
[Laughter]
but the jump back at the end that was
super clutch did you know he was going I
don't know took them up it's just it's
just basic Rasheed matchup Theory when
they when they activate v-trigger there
freeman said you know go for that exe go
spike so if you jump right if you jump
back right away you get caught with the
with the eagle spike but if you delay
the jump a little bit you'll you'll
usually catch them with your jump in
attack Big Bear was definitely like he
was panicking he was rushing if he was
smarter about it he would have tried to
approach with the with the mixer which
is which is safer but since he was
panicking he went for the Eagles play
and that let me win this is his moment
one for all the salt of the earth the
workingman people who had a hard time
break it through this is his day keeping
your composure and not panicking or
scrambling is a huge factor when it
comes to playing at a high level so I
mean are there any tips you can give
people to kind of maintain that
mentality when they blow market emotion
a night you think that's gonna for me I
really just look at tournaments as like
like a training ground the win-loss
shouldn't really matter to you of course
you know at Evo if you win you get first
player the world champion if you get if
you lose you got second and there is a
big difference there but so we're
talking a millimeter bomb in the
long-term you should look at it as like
where I was able to play well am i able
to stay consistent so if you don't focus
too much on the win-loss of each game
and try to focus on your game plan I
think that's the the easiest path to be
consistent with that said do you feel
like you know after re-watching the
match again is there anything you would
have done differently
no can you come to Noire the first game
in the second game I lost and that
really wasn't it too good I should have
realized at right after the first game
that the greatest isn't playing like he
played me in casuals so I should have
changed it up and you know started going
for the win right from that second game
that kind of tells me that I was over
valuing the experience I had against him
before a little too much so that is like
one point of like reflection for me yeah
definitely something I was gonna ask
next because a lot of the times we come
to these events and we want to play as
many casuals as possible because that's
what gets us fresh for the tournament
but now experiencing this seeing how big
bird may have sand back a little bit in
casuals before do you feel like you're
gonna take that knowledge you playing
casuals with a grain of salt next time
or how are you gonna approach casuals
moving forward on old cuckoo in when
you're in when you're in a pinch when
you're panicking you tend to fall back
on like your Breton letters what works
well so that aspect of your of your play
really doesn't change too much between
casuals and tournament play so that
experience from from from casual play is
it's pretty valuable I think and even
moving forward even even if I do lose
due to like some information that I had
from casuals I wouldn't I kind of just
brush it off and just just move on to
the next one one final question before
we wrap this up we gotta know how does
it feel to be the evolution 2019
champion like it's amazing to see like
how far you've come
you've been killing it this year it's
awesome sold and I'm gonna use this top
favor shoot fire five you know we saw a
lot of new faces some of them were you
know a bigger name I got eliminated
earlier in the tournament musical
director torpedo Mook poster party and
this year first you fire five I thought
taquito maybe five or four times and
he's beating me like three or four times
I've only been him once in tournament so
who could who - captain okay about the
diamond watch a pickle it was a evil win
on top of me beating taquito somewhere
in bracket that would have made me
really happy I respect that that is like
some real champion stuff right there
like yeah I won it's great but I wanted
taquito
to be on my list of bodies that I caught
at this event like that's God like you
deserve it absolutely everyone was so
happy to see you when it was an amazing
showing and of course congratulations
and thank you so much for analyzing your
match with us today
and in first place he finally did it the
new Street Fighter world champion
[Laughter]